[Musica]
bella tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono favi dei dogi
finalmente iniziamo alla serie su scrive
il sun limited è un altro videogame che
mi avete chiesto in tantissimi e uscito
oggi 15 febbraio è un gioco che io avevo
già pre acquistato da circa un mese o
due mesi è già anche pre installato sul
pc quindi aspettavo proprio soltanto
questo giorno per poterlo aprire
veramente sono contentissimo ragazzi
perché scribblenauts per chi non lo
conosce veramente un gioco spettacolare
adesso che partiamo capirete più o meno
di cosa si tratta per chi non lo sa vi
dico soltanto che all'inizio c'è
ovviamente la presentazione filmato
iniziale quindi raga per tutta la durata
del filmato iniziale io non parlerò
perché è epico come filmato e toglierò
anche la webcam per farvelo godere al
massimo per chi invece non lo vuole
vedere lascerò un'annotazione con
scritto a che minuto deve andare per
saltarlo e quindi niente direi che
possiamo entrare nel mondo di
scribblenauts unlimited
la nostra storia comincia con nonno
heather e in donna giudica incredibile
ma vero
nonno edgar era stato il migliore
avventuriero del pianeta nonna giulia
non era d'accordo anche lei era
un'avventuriera ed gara succedeva spesso
di giungere in luoghi rimasti nascosti
per secoli e scoprire che julie era già
lì a farsi uno spuntino la loro rivalità
continua per molte altre avventure in
una di queste
jury arrivo prima di ha in cina al nappi
rante ma il tesoro era un anello di
fidanzamento
edgar ajjouri decisero di fondare una
famiglia ed avere dei figli e la
fondarono talmente bene da carne 42 un
giorno mamma e papà diedero a me e
maxwell due incredibili regali
il primo era un globo magico che
contenta di andare ovunque nel mondo
il secondo era un fantastico taccuino su
cui era sufficiente scrivere qualsiasi
cosa per farla apparire
[Musica]
preoccupati di vederci diventare bambini
viziati
i nostri genitori decisero che dovevamo
affrontare le difficoltà del mondo
esterno in cammino verso la città
incontrando un vecchio che aveva fame
maxwell fece apparire una mela ma solo
per giocare un brutto scherzo
lamela era marcia il vecchio e
l'assaggio e la sputò arrabbiandosi
moltissimo ci lancia una specie di
incantesimo disse che eravamo viziati e
star sembrava non ci avesse fatto niente
quando però maxwell si rimise in cammino
non riuscì a seguirlo il vecchio mi
aveva lanciato una maledizione per
trasformarmi in pietra
non sapevamo cosa fare per fortuna la
fattoria di nostro fratello edwin era lì
vicino
caspita come era arrabbiato edwin era
deluso per ciò che avevamo fatto al
vecchio e disse che ci meritavamo la
maledizione
meno male che edwin conosceva gli starà
età sono oggetti magici che nascono
dalla felicità degli altri quando fai
abbastanza per farli felici trovi lista
pareggio con il suo taccuino max avrebbe
potuto fare buone azioni e recuperare
starai che sufficienti per rompere la
maledizione maxwell disse d'accordo
farò del bene a tutte le persone che
incontrerò troverò tutti lista rai del
mondo e ti libererò dalla maledizione
nei map su imprese il suo taccuino e
uscire
ok raga è veramente fantastici a me
piace un casino
ci siamo vai dal fattore a pieri
perfetto devo andare da mio fratello a
piedi
allora raga questa prima puntata si
diciamo sarà adesso c'è praticamente il
tutorial che t'insegna un po come
giocare e quindi raga per questa prima
puntata per questa prima parte di
puntata devo farlo per forza ma comunque
penso che c'è anche solo tutorial sarà
fantastico non oso immaginare dopo poi
vi dico alcune cose che avevo pensato di
fare allora vai dal fattore a piedi ci
sono guadagnano st wright aiutando edwin
con il suo pluripremiato maiale vai
facciamo vincere il maiale vai basi
inizia iniziamo sarebbe questo trasforma
più piccolo della cucciolata in un
maiale pluripremiato civile oggetto per
aiutare mazzola pulire il maiale ok
devo utilizzare ok iscriviti a casa per
pulire il maiale allora ragazzi questa è
la prima volta che utilizzo del taccuino
qualsiasi cosa e dico qualsiasi cosa io
scriva melo materializza mi poi più
avanti vi farò vedere le magie di questa
roba perché veramente fantastico
comunque un oggetto per pulire il maiale
sapone a caso trascina quest'ora da
maxwell
ok vai e marzo ed è lui a non sono io ma
perfetto siamo partiti malissimo allora
pulisci te clicca la barra di
avanzamento e per il suggerimento
corrente ok
clicca mazzoli nuovi questo oggetto
elimina trascina questo questo fino al
bidone dell'immondizia ok ed è tolto il
maiale pulite ora rendilo più grande con
un aggettivo aggiunge aggettivo allora
grande grande grande
ok l'abbiamo ingigantito aiuta il maiale
a vincere il concorso per giovani
talenti trova un aggettivo ed un nome
che descrivano tali che descrivano ali
abbastanza grandi da trasportare il
maiale ali grandi cose
adesso mi devi venire in mente lo zaino
magico contiene oggetti non sarà più
tardi ok se no sei un cazzo trascinare
fino allo zaino magico dove è qua che è
successo si sono materializzati dei
giudici
ok cosa devo fare prendi hillary dallo
zaino magico cielo trascinati
nell'angolo basso a destra ok maiale se
è un maiale avanti
ok dai che vinco io dai e tipo italia's
got talent qua è scribblenauts got
talent quelli sono gli altri due
concorrenti abbiamo vinto
vai sul podio che te lo meriti se
abbiamo vinto abbiamo vinto quanto vi
quanti soldi ho vinto ho vinto una
stella quanto vale se la vendo
raccogli e vai così mai così totale
sarai tu 1
continua bene era che abbiamo finito il
tutorial ce l'abbiamo fatta allora
questa da una parte più o meno per
capire come si gioca
guadagna frammenti aiutando le persone
10 frammenti formula 1 st wright
ok usa la modalità st wright per trovare
sì questa storia per trovare le missioni
da fare aiuta il seme a crescere
ok
allora facciamo innaffiatoio proviamo
così
ok usa
perfetto il pallino ma che cazzo merda
merda
sì il seme è diventato una pianta
carnivora sta distruggendo e sta
distruggendo fattoria merda merda merda
porca vacca come faccio la pianta chi ha
torto
l'altra opportunità di guadagnare
frammenti le 7 a livello per
ripristinare lo stato originale ok
allora resetta ok allora praticamente
quando si quando facciamo cazzate volevo
resettare il livello così almeno non
faccio casini
ok ragazzi amo ufficialmente entrati nel
mondo di scribblenauts da adesso in
avanti siamo nelle mie mani purtroppo è
veramente sarà una cosa fuori dal mondo
cosa devo fare qui aiutare questa la mia
gattina è bloccata su un albero salva la
cosa possiamo utilizzare per salvare la
gattina sull'albero
un qualcosa di semplice per salire che
ne so shuttle mettiamo shuttle perfetto
andiamo su cos'è vabbè raccoglie la cosa
l'ho preso l'ho preso
ecco a te fa vj il salvatore vicino
torna a casa mamma mia
io e il mio scatto diciamo che sono tipo
superman un po più tecnologico a
prendere le basi è stato il primo passo
per salvare l'iva e la fermata
dell'autobus per inizia letto viaggio
verso la capitale harraga stiamo per
entrare nel mondo
raga ce la stiamo per fare clic a marzo
le chance selezionava per per giocare
con qualunque fratello sbloccato ma io
voglio utilizzare maxwell perché mi è
simpaticissimo quindi da adesso in
avanti utilizzo sempre max è lui il
migliore raga non c'è niente da fare
allora capitale vai ci siamo adesso in
avanti veramente sono i dari che cosa
potrà succedere siamo nella capitale
vedo già qualche vedo già di tutto
perfetto cosa chi è questo dato che i
scribblenauts possiamo creare qualsiasi
cosa ci venga in mente nei commenti
scrivete qualcosa di divertente da
creare che ne so tipo faccio un esempio
a caso banana con le ali no facciamo
così banana alata verde
per farvi un esempio era per farvi un
esempio di quello che intendevo comunque
qualsiasi cosa vi venga in mente di
divertente scrivetelo nei commenti
date libero sfogo alla nostra fantasia e
scrivetemi qualsiasi cosa intanto questa
la butto ok perfetto allora fatemi
divertire come lo facciamo divertire
allora non lo so qualcosa di divertente
tratta mettiamo la trota così a caso
cosa che cazzo
[Musica]
vabbè si sta divertendo divertendo con
una trota
ma per come fai a divertirti con una
trota cela lanci in faccia alla gente
non ho capito però vabbè ci siamo mai
riusciti fa vj risolve tutto
c'è king kong su un tetto cos'è
accarezza accarezziamo king kong hsi è
bravo
smonta perché c'è king kong fatemi
vedere un secondo sì c'è una missione
pure cosa
fammi fallire facciamolo re coro corona
corona spero che non mi mi fabbriche il
paparazzo perfetto che cosa è successo
no no maledetti stronzi me l'hanno
ucciso
ma bastardi maledetto attacca attacca
attacca lo uccidi lo massacra mori
stronzo gli altri pure va beh a me non
ho preso uno maledetto
come ti sei permesso di uccidere al mio
amico perché l'hai fatto vabbè
attacchiamo la trota ragazzi attaccare
una trota con un hind è una cosa che
vedete soltanto nei miei video però
vabbè lasciamo perdere
vediamo di entrare da qualche parte dato
che ho passato tutti sti posti senza
entrare
andiamo prima nello spedale un attimo
però resta macchina qui che deve essere
riparata
ho parcheggiato dove non dovrei ok ci
penso io bull
lo zero non sarà che se si scrive così
sei dischi e così va ci penso io vai
monta hai parcheggiato dove non dovevi
brutto stronzo
allora cosa veicolo perfetto se c'è
carro attrezzi perfetto forse devo fare
così usa questo comando per collegare
più oggetti ok è sta roba
no sta roba smonta ok da impiantare di
seguirmi maledetto insetto devo fare
devo andare sul carro attrezzi
vai via non si parcheggia davanti agli
ospedali maledetto e ci ho pensato io
che multa per parcheggio irregolare a me
ha date la multa che lo sto tirando via
va bene mi importa
vabbè lasciamo perdere facciamo finta di
niente smonta signora ci ho pensato io
questo è il suo taccuino lo prenda
faccia a faccia questo guardia la multa
sto maledetto insetto che mi segue da
stamattina multa per stalking perché
veramente non ha senso che continui a
seguirmi e voglio vederlo dietro le
sbarre cosa fai te lo stai mangiando che
lo sta facendo
lasciamo perdere entriamo
bene stai facendo un trapianto ci penso
io
levati dalle palle io sono un grande
attore seghetto seghetto ok ci penso io
vuoi fare un gioco con me
vabbè per evitare di far diventare molto
violento questo videogame lascio perdere
elimina cosa cosa chi è questa contenuto
procedurale che cazzo vuol dire ora puoi
utilizzare il fratello di maxwell tempo
come avatar
a questo è il fratello di maxwell a
battente non m'interessa io max che me
frega dottore in servizi aiuto a
pazienti che arrivano all'ospedale ma
iniziamo aiutiamo i pazienti perché fa
vj pensa anche agli altri faccio
volontariato dottori in servizio aiuti
ai pazienti trasportati all'ospedale
sant asterisco ok bellissimo si è messo
anche il cane un gatto allora non so se
mi sono perso qualcosa ma all'ospedale
in teoria ci vanno gli esseri umani non
gli animali prova beh accarezza gatto
questo vicino sta da cani
minchia che battuto nel greco e crea
qualcosa per curarlo e che cazzo ne so
stili siringa va bene la siringa lì
magari vi sta iniettando droga non sta
neanche io però vabbè attacca attacca
cura lo
e attacca ma che cazzo fai ma perché
povero gattino dai allora è come faccio
a curarlo che ne so medicina non so
magari diamogli un moment act magari a
mal di testa
ok perfetto ma che cazzo accurato pure
quella che maledetto per questo non
corro gli animali cosa cosa che è che è
successo una dentiera perché devono
curare una dentiera ma che deve essere
un mal di denti ma che cosa vuol dire
perché mabo dentifricio ma perché devo
curare una dentiera me lo spiegate
colgate total perfetto fi grazie
torni a trovarci perfetto vediamo cosa
mi sforna ai bender e bender il robot è
rotto aiuta a farlo funzionare di nuovo
perfetto
che ne so io a fare bocca cacciavite sto
gioco raga veramente una cosa assurda
perfetto ma che meccanico ragazzi e va
bene all'ospedale si fanno anche se cosa
evidentemente ma passano potevi nei
porti o cos'è questo è il de la storia
in completa dove l'ultimo capitolo ma
faccio anche lo scrittore a tempo perso
da danni dammi evidenziatore store è
perfetto perché noi scriviamo i libri
con l'evidenziatore giustamente perfetto
dipingi ok a posto è diventato solo
giallo allora facciamo così matita
matita
matita perfetto vai ok mi manca
l'inchiostro non importano la matita
scrima che senza per che saltella perché
sta saltellando lasciamo perdere
è una ma una macchina sembra che
qualcosa si è rotto sotto il cofano
chiave inglese
ok a posto la vj l'aggiustatutto adesso
che abbiamo curato tutti i pazienti ma
basta ma quanto ce n'è a perfetto mi ha
portato st wright ci siamo e siamo a tre
[Musica]
ok totale sarai 3 perfetto vabbè andiamo
avanti
salve di cosa ha bisogno vieni più
vicino per attivarmi ok partecipe
classici giochi delle giostre per
vincere dei premi giochi delle giostre
inizio che era già facciamo si giochi
delle giostre non idea di che cosa sia
le giostre unicità lanciamo la cosa per
buttare giù le bottiglie ma non superare
la barriera ok perche sono un clown
vabbè allora facciamo così bomba a mano
a caso così proprio una granata sulle
sulle clicca due volte il target per
sparare non c'ha le cose ok lancia è
perfetto
chi è questo è un mio rivale maledetto
non c'è qualcosa per far scoppiare i
palloncini senza superare la barriera ok
oddio un qualcosa di leggero per farli
scoppiare
bazooka bazooka vai così vai guarda che
cosa succede a chi mi fotte il lavoro
maledetto da così impari cos'è sta roba
lancia qualcosa per colpire la vasca
lancia qualcosa per colpire la vasca per
tutti senza attraversare la barriera
ok la vasca per tutti allora dammi non
lo so un'altra la mina da minafra
freccetta ok mollare a un bazooka per
una freccetta è fantastico allora lancia
vinto ho vinto la mia me la stella è mia
è mia
raccogli
totale sarai tu se siamo troppo forti ok
bene ragazzi siamo cos'è questo voglio
andare per mare tsunami cos'è c'è andato
fermare la figlia
vado hanno ragazzi è fantastico è
veramente l'epicità fatta videogame è
veramente stupendo
vabbè sei contento adesso vabbè dai
poverino mi fa un po bene allora
facciamoli che ne so
nav e vai con la nave guida proprio la
vichinga proprio voi così vai o no dove
vai stronzo la stella voglio bon voyage
con varia c'e un paio di palle voglio la
stella non me l'ha data vabbè dai raga
direi che posso chiudere qui questo come
primo episodio tra filmato e tutorial
era un po diciamo per imparare per
capire come si gioca
penso che abbiate capito e dal prossimo
inizieranno veramente le cose più
assurde sono sicuro di questo
ricordatevi di lasciarmi un commento su
una cosa che volete che io materializzi
nel prossimo episodio e le più
divertenti magari le farò come al solito
se il video vi è piaciuto lasciato un
commento mi piacerà anche la pagina di
facebook che trovate come al solito
nella descrizione di ogni mio video
se non siete iscritti iscrivetevi e ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi